In the world of trading, achieving consistent profitability isn't about hitting
it big on a
single trade or riding a wave of good fortune. It's about understanding and
mastering the
interplay between technical skills and psychological resilience. Many traders
enter the market with
dreams of quick riches, but those who succeed in the long run are the ones who
grasp a fundamental
truth. Trading is not about making money. It's about preserving it. This
concept might sound
counterintuitive, especially when you're drawn to the market by the promises of
wealth.
However, once you understand the principles of risk management and the
psychology that
underpins successful trading, you'll realize that capital preservation is the
bedrock of long-term
success. The cornerstone of every successful trading strategy is risk
management. While many traders
focus on potential profits, the wise trader understands that managing risk is
the key to staying in
the game. Without proper risk management, even the most promising strategy will
eventually lead
to devastating losses. At its core, risk management involves controlling the
amount of money you put
at risk on each trade. It's not just about setting a stop-loss or take profit.
It's about having a
comprehensive plan that dictates how much of your capital you're willing to
risk at any given time.
This plan should be as detailed and unwavering as the strategy you use to find
trades in the market.
Capital preservation is not just some buzzword. It's a philosophy that under
pins every successful
trader's approach to the markets. The goal is simple. Stay in the game long
enough to let your
edge play out. In trading, losses are inevitable. No matter how skilled you are
, no matter how
much you study the markets, there will be times when the market moves against
you. The difference
between a successful trader and one who blows their account is how they manage
those losses.
Imagine a trader who risks 10% of their capital on each trade. If they hit a
losing streak of just
5 trades, they would have lost 50% of their account. To recover from that, they
would need to double
their remaining capital, which is an incredibly daunting task. On the other
hand, a trader who
just risks 1% per trade would still have 95% of their capital intact after the
same losing streak,
requiring only a 5.26% gain to return to break either. That's the power of
capital preservation.
Many traders come into the market with a short-term mindset, hoping to make
quick profits. However,
the reality is that trading is a marathon, not a sprint. Longevity in trading
is about surviving
the inevitable ups and downs of the market. It's about having the discipline to
stick to your
risk management plan even when things aren't going your way. Longevity is also
about understanding
that the market environment changes over time. What works in a bullish market
might not work
on a bearish one. And vice versa. By preserving your capital, you ensure that
you're around to
take advantage of market conditions when they're in your favor. This is why the
most successful
traders think in times of years, not just days or weeks. When most traders
think of risk management,
they think of stop-loss orders. While stop-losses are a crucial part of risk
management,
they're only one piece of the puzzle. Your stop-loss should be placed at a
level that invalidates
your trade idea. It's not about sitting in an arbitrary point that gives you a
favorable risk
to reward ratio. It's about finding a level on a chart where if price reaches
it, your trade idea
is no longer valid. Position sizing is equally important. This involves
determining how much
of your capital you will risk on any single trade. A common rule of thumb is to
risk no more than
1-2% of your account on any given trade. This ensures that even if you hit a
string of losses,
your capital remains largely intact. Position sizing also helps you avoid the
emotional rollercoaster
that comes with taking on too much risk. For example, imagine you have a $10,
000 account
and you decide to risk 1% per trade, meaning $100. If your stop-loss is 50 pips
away,
you would calculate your position size so that a 50-pip move against you would
result in a $100 loss.
This way, you maintain control over your risk, regardless of how much the
market moves.
While managing risk is crucial, no one went to take profit is equally important
.
Your take profit levels should be determined before you enter a trade. This
allows you to
manage your trades objectively, without being swayed by emotions as the trade
progresses.
There are various ways that you can set take profit levels, such as using a
fixed risk reward,
Fibonacci levels, structural levels, or liquidity levels. One approach is to
scale out of your
position as the trade moves in your favor. For example, you might decide to
take 50% of your
position off the table once that trade has moved 1.5 times your risk in your
favor. This way,
you're locking some profits while still allowing the rest of your position to
run. This strategy
not only protects your capital but also helps you maintain a positive mindset,
as you've already
secured some gains even if the trade turns against you. Scaling in and out of
positions is another
advanced risk management technique that can help you maximize your profits
while minimizing risk.
Scaling in involves adding to a winning position as the market moves in your
direction. This can
be done in stages, with each additional entry being smaller than the previous
one. The key
is to ensure that the new entry still adheres to your overall risk management
plan. Scaling out,
on the other hand, involves gradually taking profits as the trade moves in your
favor.
This allows you to lock in gains while still giving the remaining position a
chance to capture
a bigger move. The key to successful scaling is discipline. You must stick to
your plan
and avoid the temptation to add to losing positions or take profits too early.
One aspect of risk management they often overlooked is the number of trades you
take.
Every trade you enter exposes your capital to risk, so it's important to be
selective.
Many traders believe that more trades equal more opportunities to make money.
However,
in reality, more trades often lead to more losses. Each trade should be
carefully considered and
should meet all of your criteria before you enter. By limiting the number of
trades you take,
you not only reduce your exposure to risk but also increase the quality of your
trades.
It's better to take a few quality trades than to take numerous mediocre ones.
Imagine a trader who takes 20 trades a week, risking 1% of their capital on
each trade.
If their win rate is 50%, they could end up losing 10% of their account if they
hit a
losing streak. On the other hand, a trader who takes just 5 carefully selected
trades a week
with the same win rate might only lose 2.5% in a losing streak. By being
selective,
the second trader not only preserves their capital but also maintains a clear
online set.
Risk management is not just about numbers. It's also about psychology.
Several cognitive biases can undermine your risk management plan if you're not
aware of them.
These biases can cause you to deviate from your plan, leading to poor decision-
making and
unnecessary losses. Let's dive in to some of the most common biases that I see
in traders.
The first is overconfidence. Overconfidence can lead you to take on more risks
than you should.
After a series of winning trades, you might start to believe that you're
invincible,
leading you to increase your position sizes or take trades that don't beat your
criteria.
This can quickly and usually does lead to significant losses. The second is
loss aversion.
Loss aversion is the tendency to fear losses more than you value gains. This
can cause you to hold
onto your losing trades far too long, hoping that they will turn around or to
take profits
too early out of a fear that the market will reverse. Both of these behaviors
can undermine
your risk management plan. Third is the confirmation bias. Confirmation bias is
the tendency to look
for information that confirms your beliefs while ignoring information that
contradicts them.
In trading, this can lead you to focus only on the signals that support your
trade idea while
ignoring those that suggest that you may be wrong. This can result in you
taking trades that don't
fully meet your criteria or holding onto losing trades longer than you should.
The next is recency bias. Recency bias is the tendency to give more weight to
recent events
than to historical data. This can cause you to overreact to a recent loss or
win, leading you to
deviate from your risk management plan. For example, after a big loss, you
might reduce your position
sizes too much, missing out on the potential profits. Conversely, after a big
win, you might be led to
increase your position size too much, leading to larger losses. The key to
overcoming these
cognitive biases is emotional control. Successful traders are the ones who can
maintain a calm,
rational mindset, even in the face of losses. This is easier said than done,
but it can be achieved
through proper practice and discipline. One of the most effective ways to
maintain emotional
control is to have a clear written trading plan that includes your risk
management rules. By following
this plan, you can remove much of the emotion from your trading and make
decisions based on logic
rather than fear or greed. Another important aspect of emotional control is
understanding
that losses are just a part of trading. No matter how good your strategy is,
you will have losing
trades. The key is to accept these losses as a normal part of the process and
stick to your risk
management plan, even when things aren't going your way. Now I want to touch on
the importance
of mindfulness in trading. Mindfulness is the practice of being fully present
and aware of your
thoughts, feelings and actions in the present moment. In trading, mindfulness
can help you stay
focused and avoid being swept away by emotions. By being mindful, you can
observe your thoughts
and feelings without reacting to them, allowing you to make more rational
decisions. For example,
if you notice that you're feeling anxious about a trade, you can take a step
back and ask yourself
why? Is it because the trade doesn't fully meet your criteria? Is it because
you're
overexposed to risk? By identifying the source of your anxiety, you can take
steps to address it,
whether that means adjusting your position size, moving your stop loss or
exiting the trade altogether.
Mindfulness can also help you to stay disciplined in your risk management. By
being aware of your
emotions, you can resist the urge to deviate from your plan, even when the
market is moving
against you. This can help you avoid impulsive decisions that could lead to
unnecessary losses.
Let's talk about emotional resilience. Emotional resilience is the ability to
bounce back from
setbacks and keep moving forward. In trading, this means being able to handle
losses without
letting them affect your confidence of your decision-making. It's about staying
focused on the long-term
goal of consistent profitability, even when things aren't going your way. One
way to develop
emotional resilience is to reframe your thinking about losses. Instead of
seeing them as failures,
view them as learning opportunities. Every loss can teach you something about
your trading strategy,
your risk management, or even your mindset. By focusing on what you can learn
from each loss,
you can turn setbacks into stepping stones to success. Another important aspect
of emotional
resilience is having a support system. Trading can be a lonely and stressful
endeavor,
especially when you're going through a rough patch. Having a mentor, a trading
buddy,
or a community of like-minded traders can provide you with the encouragement
and support
you need to stay on track. Let's take a look at the role of data in risk
management, and more
specifically tracking and analyzing your trades. To effectively manage risk,
you need to have a
deep understanding of your trading performance. This means keeping detailed
records of all your
trades and regularly reviewing them to identify patterns and areas for
improvement. A trading
journal is an essential tool for this. In your journal, you should record the
details of each
trade, including your entry and exit points, your stop-loss and take-profit
levels, your position
size, and the outcome of the trade. You should also know any emotions or
thoughts that you had
during the trade, as these can provide valuable insights into your current
mindset. By regularly
reviewing your trading journal, you can identify patterns in your behavior that
might be undermining
your risk management. For example, you might notice that you tend to take too
much risk
after a winning streak or that you often move your stop-losses when you're
feeling anxious.
By identifying these patterns, you can take steps to address them and therefore
improve your risk
management. Data is also crucial for refining your risk management plan. By
analyzing your data,
you can identify what works and what doesn't. For example, you might find that
certain types of
trades consistently result in losses or others are more profitable. You might
also discover that
certain market conditions are more conducive to your trading strategy than
others. This information
can be used to refine your risk management plan, making it tailored to your
specific trading style
and goals. For example, if you find that you tend to do better in trending
markets,
you might decide to reduce your position sizes or avoid trading altogether
during periods of
consolidation. By using data to inform your risk management decisions, you can
make your trading
more systematic and less prone to emotional decision-making. This can
ultimately help you
stay disciplined and stick to your plan even when the market is volatile.
Let's talk about diversifying your trading portfolio. One advanced risk
management strategy
is diversification. Just as investors diversify their portfolios to spread risk
across different
asset classes, traders can diversify their trades to reduce risk. This might
involve trading multiple
currency pairs, asset classes or even different trading strategies. The key to
successful diversification
is to ensure that the trades or strategies you're using are not highly
correlated. For example,
if you're trading multiple currency pairs, you should avoid trading pairs that
are likely to
move in the same direction. By diversifying your trades, you can reduce the
impact of any single
loss on your overall portfolio. Diversification can also help you smooth your
equity curve,
making your trading more consistent over time. However, it's important to note
that diversification
isn't a substitute for good risk management. You still need to have a solid
risk management
plan in place for each trade or strategy that you use. Hedging is another
advanced risk
management strategy that can help you protect your capital. Hedging involves
taking a position
in one market to offset the risk of the position in another market. For example
,
if you're long on a currency pair, you might take a short position in a
correlated pair
to hedge your risk. Hedging can be a powerful tool, but it does require a deep
understanding
of the market and how they interact. It's also important to remember that hed
ging can reduce your
potential profits as well as your risk. Therefore, it's important to weigh the
benefits and drawbacks
carefully before using this. Options are another tool that can be used for risk
management. Options
give you the right, but not the obligation, to buy or sell an asset at a
specific price before a
certain date. This can be used to hedge your trades or to limit your risk. For
example,
if you're long on a stock, you could buy a put option to protect yourself
against a decline in
the stock's price. If a stock falls below the strike price at the option, you
can exercise the
option and sell the stock at the strike price, limiting your loss. Options can
be complex and
carry their own risks, so it's important to fully understand how they work
before using them in
your risk management strategy. However, for traders who are comfortable with
them,
options can provide an additional layer of protection against market volatility
.
Let's take a look at the role of technology when it comes to risk management.
There are various
software tools available that can help you manage risk more effectively. There
are various software
tools available in the market that can help you manage your risk more
effectively. These tools
can do various things, included but not limited to, calculating your position
sizes, setting your
stock losses and your target profit levels, and executing automatically. Some
risk management
softwares out there can even help you analyze your trading performance,
identifying patterns in
your behavior, and providing insights into how you can improve your risk
management. By using these
tools, you can make your trading more systematic and less prone to emotional
decision-making.
The trading world is constantly evolving, and so is the technology that
supports it.
To stay competitive, it's important to stay up-to-date with the latest
developments in
trading technology. This might involve learning a new software, experiment with
automated systems,
or staying informed about the latest trend in the market. By staying up-to-date
with technology,
you can ensure that you're using the best tools available to manage your risk
and maximize your
trading performance. Artificial intelligence is something that is set to
revolutionize risk
management and trading. AI can analyze vast amounts of data in real-time,
identifying patterns and
trends that might be missed by human traders. This can help you make more
informed decisions and
manage risk more effectively. For example, AI can be used to analyze historical
trading data,
identifying the conditions under which your strategy is most likely to succeed
or fail.
This information can then be used to refine your risk management plan,
making it more tailored to your specific trading style and goals. AI can also
be used to monitor
your trades in real-time, alerting you to potential risks or opportunities as
they arise.
This can help you stay ahead of the market and make more informed decisions.
However,
it's obviously important to remember that AI is not a magic bullet. While it
will and can provide
viable insights, it's still up to you to make the final decision. Therefore, it
's important to
use AI as a tool to support your trading rather than trying to rely on it
entirely.
In conclusion, risk management is the cornerstone of successful trading. It's
not just about sitting
a stop-loss or calculating position sizes. It's about having a comprehensive
plan that governs
every aspect of your trading. By understanding the psychology of risk
management and using the tools
and techniques available to you, you can protect your capital, maximize your
profits and ultimately
ensure your longevity in trading. As trading continues to evolve, so too will
the tools and
strategies used to manage risk. By staying informed about the latest
developments and continuously
refining your risk management plan, you can stay ahead of the curve and make
sure that you're
able to achieve consistent profitability over the longest period of time.